hello everybody
enjoying the conference so far ah good
good well let's change the trend with
this presentation then
um all right um i have a few slides it's
mostly going to be a live coding session
or with all the
like the problems that can generate i
hope there are not too many
um a little bit about me that's my
twitter handle
um uh you might know me uh for uh
like a weekly blog post about closure
that is sent out every
every week yeah um if you don't know
it's it's a very short thing it's
getting some traction
and uh it is quite useful i think all
about
closure and libraries and standard
libraries and everything
i'm lead developer working at a
london-based company called
wgsn that is doing fashion forecasting
a little warning there will be closure
we we don't
have time to look into the language
problems uh so um you you need you need
to know a little bit of closure to
follow this
um a little bit of background what we're
talking about so there were
a few attempts already in the closure
library to
introduce parallelism uh the first one
probably
uh pmap uh introduced with 1.0
is a mapping each element of a
collection
into its own thread or future sending
them out for computation
and they're collecting collecting them
back after the results
it is a simple approach it has
limitations especially if the function
is not doing a lot of work
you're wasting mostly time with the
parallelization and the threading
sending out those as like workers
external workers instead if your
function is doing quite a lot it's quite
heavy
then that could be a good approach as
this for mapping specifically
a deprecated form of reducing in
parallel
was introduced at some point later this
is based on the
fort join framework jsr 166
that was introduced officially in the
jdk 7
and this is just a wrapper around that
so it's not doing anything closure side
it's just mapping
collections into a parallel array of
the the library and waiting for the
results to come back
an experimental another experiment
experiment on fork joint was done with
the pv map is
an experimental branch still visible
from github
and that was a better attempt
like a better result i think at the
attempt
since like the the collection
manipulation the splitting into multiple
pieces was down the closure side
and then sent off to fork joint and
reduces is kind of uh
accumulating all the experience into
like a
more composable and clean interface and
this is what we are going to see today
in general you will see also functional
property composition
some functional items and a few
refactoring moves that might be helpful
also outside reduces feel free to
interrupt anytime
i'll try to go fast because there is no
a lot of time
what is our goal we would like to see
how
reducers enclosure work by
basically rewrite them
from scratch and we'll start with one
simple
sorry three simple goals one function
is our goal uh that has a similar
interface to reduce so we don't we are
not changing semantic we
we use what we know and uh can accept
transformations other than reduce so i
can do other
i can apply other functions on top of
reduce which is the like the final
what is generating the results that
means like incrementing that means
uh in you know manipulating a map
depending on your
context and hopefully
efficient parallelization so all these
transformations and the reduce
the reduce operation should happen like
in the same
loop it shouldn't i shouldn't need to
send off for parallelization the map
then wait for the results and then send
off the reduce and wait for the results
should that all happen in the same thing
and so let's get started
quick check can you see good
from far behind as well good so we're
going to use
uh definitely uh some sort of collection
for the entire length of the
presentation so we're going to create
something we can use so keep an
eye on the
bottom bottom left
bottom left corner for results to appear
and this should work
ah yeah we are not starting good right
yeah this will happen um so we are
searching for something like this
parallel reduce that takes maybe
this is an example associative
plus a seed of some sort
so as i can get the key right and it's a
platon collection
this of course does not exist let's
create that
and we'll start working on this one
take some associative uh some function
a seed and a collection
okay and just for like see if
everything is hooked up just invoke
reduce
so for 49.50
is what we get i'll save it here just to
see if everything is
coherent um
so what if we want to do we want to
introduce parallelization in this then
turns out is not that difficult
um yeah there are some complexities that
we are going to skip but
it's going to be something like this
we could try to
split the collection in two parts
and then concentrate on each of the each
of these plates
so stakes are back of the collection
from
zero to the split
and collection something
to this from display to the rest
and oh forgot the parenthesis
and once no it's matching another one
yeah once we have this
what we should do is when we then we
need to decide when but we
when we reach a leaf
let's say this is completely arbitrary
so the collection should be
small enough to be sent off to a worker
let's say 50. that depends on
the number of cores you have available
or the number of workers
and mainly the kind of computation
you're doing so you need to
find out what is the best uh sub
splitting
where you need to stop so when you have
this well okay
that's is when it's time to do the
actual reduce if you were not at that
point then you keep on invoking so
you produce it again you see it on the
first collection
and on the second
while i'm using g i'm i need to combine
those two
splits when the results come back and
one way of doing that
is using the same associative function
you're using for reduce
that's not always the case that's why in
the
reducers framework you can pass in your
combining function and override the
behavior but in this case is simple
enough
plus can uh bring together its results
all right so it's time to try
oops here we go
so it's still working as expected is not
going to in parallel but
we achieved the like the functional
composition then
this is where you need to do something
and if you look at the
reduced sources you will see that here
is where we are using the fork join to
send off
tasks for each one of the two sub
collections
and getting back results and combine
them
cool are we happy um
yes but yeah we achieved some sort of
parallelization but
what if we don't want to do just a
reducing this operation then let's say i
want to do
let's increment uh
on each element of the collection also
so that is going to change the result of
course
but if i do this the mappings that i can
incrementing each elemental collection
is not going in parallel is
is applied before and then is sent off
to the parallelization
so this is not what we want so it's not
efficient
well we can simply take maybe
control of that plus and
if we take control of that plus then we
can decide what to do
with the two elements
of the computation this is still the
same thing
oh wait now i'm going to remove
the increment here
and i can add it here
so each time i have an element i
increment it
numbers are different you will maybe
notice
and this is not due to what we are doing
yes so it's because we need to introduce
a little bit more
complexity if you want uh the increment
of the reduce to be the same in both
places and this is depending on the seed
and the way the computation is done uh
there's a way of to fix it i'm not going
to fix it now
but it's generally is doing what we
expect
is incrementing and summing all the
numbers up
uh all right are we happy yes
but we're not talking about plus or
incrementing every time so maybe we do
we should just make sure that we can
generalize this thing so it is true that
i can always
wrap a function into another function
without altering the results
but i need to invoke it now nope not
basically
there must be a parenthesis right yes
still the same so now
i can extract the operation here let's
call it f
so instead of ink i'm passing that down
and i can decide if this is going to be
an ink
or is it going to be something else good
same for plus is not going to be always
a plus the kind of
reduction we are doing so we can apply
the same
principle again wrap it
empty for the moment then we need to
invoke it twice
and we can extract let's call it g
and we now need to pass it down
yeah is it better yes
it's general but with this produce at
the moment we kind of went away from
the original reducer semantics so we are
invoking something on this reduction
operation on the plus
and then passing down the collection
wondering if
we can go back to what we are used to
like to mapping the collection with an
increment and then reducing it
so it turns out that we can push this
plus increment
here down to the collection and
the way this can be done is because
reduce is
the reduced implementation is based on
protocols and
we can just refine that protocol so that
we take
control over the reducing operation on
that collection
and we do we can do whatever we want uh
let's see if i can illustrate this
let's create a reducer function
the names start to go in the direction
the right direction as well
that takes like a transforming function
and the collection
and we redefine here over
core closure
protocols call reduce which is where
this
where this thing lives and
this protocol has one function with two
rdts
and we need to provide those call reduce
with implicit collection coming in off
f is the function
and call reduce implicit thing coming in
with a seed
so one is with a c the other is not um
all right so we need to do something
here um we don't need to do
like fancy stuff we can just invoke the
normal call reduce
which is defined for vectors and the
other types
but we can apply our transformation in
the mix
which is what we want so
oh yeah yeah thank you
that was about to throw a nasty
error to catch good thank you
all right uh code reduce of collection
and the transformation
fx applied to f
so f is our associative function we are
we are taking that function and do what
we did in our example before so we are
applying some transformation on top of
it
and we got a seed here that we need to
pass
so that could be 0 but that is valid for
plus
and maybe other uh associative functions
it's not true for everything um one conv
one convention we can take is that we
can invoke
the reducing function without arguments
and
let that function return as what should
be considered the seed for the kind of
operation
this is not always true uh is a i'm just
trying to reduce the complexity and the
reducer framework
what is done here is that your is your
combining function that is giving this
result instead of the reducing function
but we can use it here
um to reduce a little bit complexity so
i don't need to send around the
combining function and we need something
similar
but we know what the seed is here
seed and we just pass it down
so it's closing
[Music]
not and that
okay so this is going to throw an error
um
[Music]
oh not this one though
this one right let's see if it's
balanced
good ah yeah
still working because we are not using
it um
let's try to use it now so now that we
refined the protocol
we can push down to the collection what
we need
so we pass we transform this collection
with this reducer function
passing down what we want like this
should be
incremented in this case and
we don't need this anymore
okay so the problem now
is that this produced
function that we created doesn't know
what to do with the
refiled object so the type of this
collection has changed it used to be
like some sort of vector but now that we
are re-finding it
this way is turning back as another type
so it's throwing
that i cannot count on this kind of
collection which is not
a collection it's a refined collection
we need to do something similar for
produce basically we need to
create some protocol and make sure that
when we are
refined on the uh reduce call reduce
protocol we also refund on our protocol
so it takes the collection instead of
the refined collection
how do you do that we need a protocol
let's create the protocol
and we call it maybe
call parallel
and this has one cool
parallel thing
that is invoked on a
collection some function g
and a seed and is implemented
using our produce
oh sorry it's not implemented here this
is just the definition of the protocol
and we are going to
refine the protocol here
so our collection
called parallel
i'm going to explain what i'm doing in a
second
uh this is implicit argument
this is some function g
this is the seed and what we need to do
is call our
produce and now we pass the collection
that is not
the refined version of it which is
coming down from the
parameters in the main function and we
still need to
transform g and then we pass the seed
i'm not sure if our produce is taking
that order of arguments
no it's taking g seed in collection so
we need to do
this g seed and the collection goes at
the end
so that we've done that
oh yes now that we have done that
we need to invoke the protocol instead
of produce
which is the what knows what to do with
the reified collection
which is what we are passing
and call producing this context yeah
yeah that's correct and i'm
i'm invoking the wrong the wrong method
name the function name
called parallel protocol not found
i'm asked i'm probably doing some
strange thing here
call parallel
call parallel
yeah this is expected bear with me a
second
i usually spot it uh produce
why produce here oh yes
it's called produce g seed and
collection
g seed and the collection
hmm i'm invoking the
protocol method and i'm using the
reducer
[Music]
can you spot anything
yeah all right exactly i forgot this
we had to invert thanks we had to
invert the the parameters order so
we now got the plus here and the seed at
the end
and it's probably still
wait a second why am using plus here
thought it was plus here
so i say it again
here yeah now this g is passing down
here
so collection gc let me let me see
all right i'm calling call parallel
which is correct
on what it says here in the protocol so
it takes a collection
a function and a seed i have the
collection here
which is going down
through the reducer with
the transforming function and
then it requires the seed
and the operator
i'm calling
here
is correct i think reducer is taking
the increment the transforming function
and the collection
and is refined called parallel
uh so i'm working this protocol
collection g and seed oh yeah
g and seed
ah too bad
then this is saying cannot be cast
so yeah it seems that i'm still
inverting somewhere the order
and this this one is getting the wrong
order so this is g
the seed and the collection am i doing
that
g seed and the collection
and this is correct
call reduce oh man
okay
um
and g
because
yeah that's ink
[Music]
collection is refined here all right
um i don't want to like um
i thought i could see i could spot it uh
if i cannot spot it i'll probably just
move um move forward
and see if i can fix it unfortunately
this yeah
i tried my best not to uh
not to get lost during the presentation
and yeah things that happen i suppose
so the reducer
yes you should you have two calls
that i think is correct
oh so it may be that
ah too bad
that seemed a good thing because it was
like like i
made a mistake with uh parenthesis
so go oh okay so
um
i'm pretty sure i was using both of them
but
yes it's the same
classic plastic is is sending them
down the the wrong order this is what
happens is uh
is is trying to use plus
uh so he's trying to uh uh is receiving
plus as the seed here in the produce
for some reason i don't understand there
might be a
an inversion somewhere that i'm i'm not
i'm not seeing at the moment all right i
i just want to move forward um
what is the line sorry
sorry
the ink is already used where
i'm listening to you because
there you go all right
but it's not applying the increments now
right
i'm pretty sure it is it is the
transformation applied to g
is that i cannot spot where i'm i'm
doing
like some something odd with the
arguments i'm inverting them
uh also wondering if no is
is not the cache right like this
maybe getting well you don't want to ink
plus you want to
you want to produce a function that is
the result
of doing both right
i'm pushing that down to uh
the collection so
uh if i invoke call parallel which is
defined here
and stick in the collection
ng and the seed it should work up
yeah unfortunately it's not let's move
on let's move on there's no
i don't think there is time to to fix it
and i already lost enough
time all right let me find
where we can move uh without this
well basically so you need to bear with
me
and i cannot like execute it and show
you the results
but do we like this form uh not really
the problem with this is that is still
inverting the order of the arguments
compared to
the normal reduce but this is easily
fixable
if we just wrap it into
something that can be called fold that
takes
some g seed in the collection
and if we do this inside
call parallel with
this stays out
with g that is coming from the above
and plus and zero
we can invert this and just invoke fold
on plus
the seed and the reduced collection
that knows how to map
um
yeah in this uh
this should be really call
uh whatever is the protocol saying
and i think this goes
goes to the beginning when we obtain the
form of fold that we want are we
um we should verify we're still happy so
we are able to uh map a transformation
on the collection
so we push that into the collection we
are
uh
sorry capslock we
something happened here
okay um we
we we kind of obtain an api that is
similar to reduce
with fault um what can we do now
um well there is a similar process and
probably i have to escape how to do it
to
apply other kind of transformation so we
were talking about an increment in this
case but
filtering is not very different from
this filtering can be applied
just by creating a function here
i'll probably see what i did wrong but
there's no time
a similar to this function plus but
where instead of applying the
transformation every time we verify
predicate and then we have we apply it
or not decide
based on that and
with that filter in place we can also
compose them
because at this point here this reducer
can be composed with comp or something
similar
in order to attain obtain a similar
result
and i think is pretty much
it there was um
something else i could show you um
so this is basically if you look inside
the reducers
library the source file
you will see more or less what this was
done in the right way
uh plus including all the complexities
that i had to skip
uh to like make it quicker and
but this basically the principles are
all there um
you you just wrap uh the collection in
in into a reified uh version of it
that can support the entrance the the
concatenation of transformation you need
um one use of one use i can show you
of reducers if you want to play with
them
is on a on a library i created
which is called pwc which is a parallel
version of wc the
accounting utility in unix
systems if you uh brew tap
that taps location and then you
reinstall pwc you will have it available
and when you have it available it's just
uh
going into some maybe find some big file
and then a pwc on it
to like obtain the same results that
pwc is sorry the the the sequential wc
is giving you back
um there is an additional printing
frequency frequencies thing
so this is basically an application of
uh
reducers applied to uh
applied it to the word the usual word
count problem
um i can give you see there are other
two minutes i can give you an idea of uh
how that it was done
this is the entry point uh but what
basically this is doing is using the
user's library
with a combination function and um
a combination of other mapping and
transformation
on top and basically the
the important part of it is
this reducing counter which is the
transforming function on top of the
reduce that is going to happen next
uh which is taking line by line is
splitting the line into words
and then it's counting them up uh into a
map that is then the
uh the result of the
reducing at the end and
i think it's pretty much it um i'm of
course i'm
i'm sorry it happened uh it was kind of
like one of the expected results i i
took the
uh like the the challenge i usually like
to do it and or
sometimes i screw screw up way
pretty badly um there are any questions
i can answer
have you posted your pwc code anywhere
oh yes it's um sorry resources is on
github
and this is a few links but you
if you look up my little twitter handle
on github you'll find pwc in my
in my projects but that is the the
link um i also wrote an article for sd
for the sd journal uh with
a little bit of the the concepts i
explained today
and there's a little bit of history as
well so if you want a little bit more
background it's available for free
i think you you need to register but
it's free
give an email any other questions
it's not faster at the moment um
[Music]
one reason i'm i think i can make it
faster but it's
wc is really really hard to beat
it's not faster because i'm also doing
frequencies
and even if i skip the the like
calculation the real calculation of the
frequencies i'm
still introducing a little bit of
overhead to keep
the count of each word um and the other
thing is there are optimization i still
need to do
is like a work in progress side project
and the two main important one is
i shouldn't use any regasp you might
have seen that
here those are
if you fire up a profiler when the pwc
is running you will see that that is
what is taking most of the time
at the moment and to split
a sentence into words in a simple way
you can do without for gasps
and other things are putting types so i
avoid reflections reflection uh overhead
by closure just i'm talking about
strings all the time
so that's is not faster it's
10 15 seconds slower at the moment
planning to make it faster i hope so
any other question
all right thank you have a good lunch